j'ai qui vous êtes priés d'arriver une
drôle la semaine dernière non oui
effectivement j'étais j'ai tapé ses
clients pour changer ainsi la halle et
cette cliente me paraît un petit peu
bizarre elle était derrière moi se
frotte y ait un petit peu partout et le
pied rage même temps pour travailler
j'ai demandé une embellie trick
c'est ce que s'est proposé de me donner
et c'est éclairé entre les jambes heures
et alors j'ai tout vu il faut noter mal
à bien trop de condamine quatrième étage
droite
dans la demi-heure qui suit vous aura
des panneaux au revoir mes amis
le dépannage les équipes alternent
inquiète pas non jacky d'un apport de 3
heures moi je veillerai
c'est pas peu dire d'être femme d'un
serrurier 6e assez difficile surtout je
suis très jaloux parce qu'il a des
aventures à y en a et d'un art il y en a
eu beaucoup
il y aura certainement d'autres et c'est
à dire qu'il beaucoup d'occasions donc
c'est pas tellement il félicité j'ai des
panneaux mis clients ou vers un port qui
a fait la facture après bien en faire un
verre deux verres trois verres et d'un
seul coup on m'a demandé alors vous
déshabiller pas au est alors qu'ici vous
avez fait je fais ce que m'a demandé et
vous pensez que il n'y a pas de raison
d'en faire une histoire
non je pense pas non non non je pense
qu'il faut vivre sa vie' j'ai envie de
vivre ma vie comme ça et puis on ne
changera pas
ah voilà génial n'être ni écouter samedi
matin bertrand corre plaisir
oh